Bob Harris has won two cars and a lot of money playing Jeopardy on television. But he insists he's not that smart. What he is, he says, is somebody who decided when he was going to be on Jeopardy to take measures.
鲍勃·哈里斯在电视游戏节目《危险边缘》中赢过两辆车和一大笔奖金。但他坚持认为自己并不聪明。他说，他只是一个在决定参加《危险边缘》时就采取了相应措施的人。
I told my girlfriend at the time, hi. I'm rearranging the furniture now. And I need to make my house look like the Jeopardy studio. I set up low bookcases to be sort of like where the podiums were, about the same height. And I would stand there. I had a little homemade buzzer that I made out of a ballpoint pen and some masking tape.
我当时告诉女朋友，嘿，我现在要重新布置家具。我得让我的房子看起来像《危险边缘》的演播室。我摆放了一些矮书架，高度和讲台差不多。我会站在那里。我有一个用圆珠笔和美纹纸胶带自制的小蜂鸣器。
He got bright halogen lights. And he pumped up the air conditioning to make it feel like the inside of a TV studio. He placed a big picture of Jeopardy's host, Alex Trebek, in about the spot where the real Alex Trebek stands.
他买来了明亮的卤素灯，还调大了空调，让房间里感觉就像电视演播室内部一样。他在真正的亚历克斯·特雷贝克站立的位置附近，放了一张巨大的《危险边缘》主持人亚历克斯·特雷贝克的照片。
I even tried to time my meals to when I would be eating at Jeopardy, so that my whole body clock would be exactly in harmony.
我甚至尝试调整我的用餐时间，以配合我在《危险边缘》中比赛的时间，这样我的生物钟就能完全合拍。
So he played along with videotapes of the TV show. And he studied for months, memorizing all kinds of stuff, the guys who ran the United Nations in order, the presidents in order, rivers, the elements, British kings, the novels of E. M. Forster-- which include, by the way, Room With a View, Where Angels Fear to Tread, Howards End.
于是他跟着电视节目的录像带一起玩。他学习了几个月，背诵了各种东西：联合国历任负责人、历任总统、河流、元素、英国国王、E.M.福斯特的小说——顺便说一下，包括《看得见风景的房间》、《天使不敢涉足的地方》、《霍华德庄园》。
The way to remember a lot of stuff is to build really big, goofy images. It takes an extra couple of seconds, maybe even a minute or two of thought, but then it stays better. So it's time well invested. I made this big picture in my head of a room with a view. OK, so you've got this nice, really big, like-- a friend of mine in Ohio grew up in this big mansion, so it's actually his living room in my head. So OK, it's a room with a beautiful view.
记住大量东西的方法是构建非常宏大、古怪的图像。这需要多花几秒钟，甚至一两分钟的时间来思考，但这样记的效果更好。所以这是值得的投资。我在脑海里画了一幅大大的“看得见风景的房间”的图。好吧，你拥有这个漂亮、特别大的房间——我在俄亥俄州的一个朋友就是在这样的豪宅里长大的，所以我脑海里用的就是他的客厅。所以，好吧，这是一个拥有美丽风景的房间。
And Howards End was the next one on the list that I just happened to have in front of me. And so Howards End , and you've got A Room With a View . I mean, how can you not have, like, Howard-- I have a friend named Howard. And so I made a 30-foot buttocks and stuck it in the window. So you have a room with a view of Howard's end where angels fear to tread. So the angels are in this room, and there's this giant 30-foot buttocks in the window.
《霍华德庄园》是我清单上的下一部，正好就在我面前。所以《霍华德庄园》，再加上《看得见风景的房间》。我的意思是，怎么能没有“霍华德”呢——我有个朋友叫霍华德。所以我做了一个30英尺高的屁股，把它插在窗户里。这样你就拥有了一个能看到“霍华德庄园”的、天使不敢涉足的风景房间。天使就在这个房间里，窗户里还有一个30英尺高的巨大屁股。
That's why the angels fear to tread there.
这就是为什么天使不敢涉足那里的原因。
Who really wants to be there, really?
谁真的想待在那儿呢？
All I can say is, you do not want to know how he got Passage to India in there. Bob says that a third of the answers that he gave on television-- a third-- came from cramming information into his head with these weird pictures that he would create for himself. And one of his biggest wins came when-- thanks to brute memorization-- he knew the name of an old book called The Compleat Angler, which to this day he has never read, has only the vaguest idea what it's about. And one of his biggest losses came when he could not remember the poem, "Jabberwocky."
我只能说，你肯定不想知道他是怎么把《印度之行》塞进去的。鲍勃说，他在电视上给出的答案中，有三分之一——三分之一——来自于他用这些为自己创造的古怪图片强行塞进脑子里的信息。他最大的一次胜利是因为——多亏了死记硬背——他知道一本叫《捕鱼全书》的旧书的名字，直到今天他都没读过，甚至对它的内容只有最模糊的概念。而他最大的一次失败是因为他记不起那首《杰伯沃基》诗了。
And I was particularly frustrated because this was my father's favorite poem. And he recited it to me pretty constantly. And yet, when they asked me about it under pressure, I just completely choked. And so Brillig became my nickname, for some people.
我感到特别沮丧，因为这是我父亲最喜欢的诗。他经常给我背诵。然而，当他们在压力下问我时，我完全卡住了。所以，有些人给我起了个绰号叫“布里利格”。
I wonder if the reason why you didn't remember it was because it wasn't part of your Jeopardy knowledge, but because it was part of your real knowledge.
我想知道你没记住的原因，是不是因为它不是你《危险边缘》知识储备的一部分，而是你真实知识的一部分。
I think that's exactly right. I think there are a lot of times in the game-- most of the big mistakes I ever made were like that, where it wasn't in my Jeopardy notebooks, my study materials, the almanacs.
我想那正是原因所在。我觉得游戏里有很多时候——我犯过的大多数重大错误都是这样的，那些内容并不在我的《危险边缘》笔记本、学习资料或年鉴里。
It's funny. It's sort of like it was in the wrong section of your brain.
真有趣。就像它被存放在了大脑里错误的区域一样。
Yeah, exactly. It was in my real brain, the one I walk around with that doesn't have much in it.
是的，完全正确。它在我的“真实大脑”里，就是我平时带着走的、里面没装多少东西的那个。
Talking to Bob about all this, you realize that a show like Jeopardy, a quiz show, any quiz show on the surface seems like it's about facts, retrieving facts to win prizes. But what's really going on for the players is totally different than just retrieving facts. There's a whole inner world happening, an inner world that is not on TV at all, an inner world that actually may be a lot more interesting than what's in the program that's on TV.
和鲍勃谈论这一切时，你会意识到像《危险边缘》这样的智力竞赛节目，表面上似乎是关于事实的，是为了赢得奖品而提取事实。但对于参赛者来说，真实发生的事情与单纯提取事实完全不同。这是一个完整的内心世界，一个电视上根本看不到的内心世界，一个可能比电视节目本身更有趣的内心世界。
Well today, we dive in to look at that inner world, at the secret life of quiz shows. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in three rounds. Round One, Gamester of Ireland is Fine. The round is about somebody who goes on to Who Wants to Be a Millionaire , and the most amazing thing he comes up with is not any fact, not any answer, it is the sheer courage to appear at all.
今天，我们将深入探讨那个内心世界，探讨智力竞赛节目的秘密生活。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为三轮。第一轮，爱尔兰玩家很棒。这一轮讲的是一个参加《谁想成为百万富翁》的人，他带来的最惊人的东西不是任何事实，也不是任何答案，而是他敢于登台的纯粹勇气。
Round Two, Dire Enigmas for Elite Fans, where we visit with some of the best quiz masters anywhere on an all-weekend, all-day, all-night quiz bender.
第二轮，精英粉丝的难题，我们将跟随一些最顶尖的测验大师，进行一场持续整个周末、全天候的测验狂欢。
Round Three, Girls in Need of a Safer Time. By the way, if you are noticing anything special about these round names, five points for you as you play along at home. Anyway, round three is an attempt to use quiz shows-- yes, quiz shows-- to change teenage girls. Stay with us.
第三轮，需要更安全时代的女孩们。顺便提一下，如果你注意到了这些轮次名称有什么特别之处，在家玩的朋友可以给自己加五分。总之，第三轮是试图利用智力竞赛节目——没错，就是智力竞赛——来改变少女。请继续收听。
Act One, Gamester of Ireland is Fine. When Ronan Kelly went to talk to the guy in this next story, all he knew about him was that he had won a lot of money on a quiz show on RTE, which is the main television station in Ireland. And Ronan just figured that anybody who had won that kind of money must have some kind of story to tell. And anyway, the guy lived nearby. So Ronan got onto his bike with his recording gear, and he bicycled over to the guy's house.
第一幕，爱尔兰玩家很棒。当罗南·凯利去采访这个故事里的主角时，他只知道这人在爱尔兰的主要电视台RTE的一个智力竞赛节目中赢了很多钱。罗南心想，能赢那么多钱的人一定有什么故事可以讲。反正这人就住在附近。于是罗南带着录音设备骑上自行车，骑到了那人的家里。
When he got there, he figured that the first thing they would do is watch the video of the guy on the quiz show. But although this man had won hundreds of thousands of pounds, he actually did not have the technology to do that. What you're about to hear is the story that Ronan put together for Irish radio about this guy. The guy is named Roger Dowds.
他到那里时，心想他们第一件事肯定会看那个人在节目里的录像。但尽管这人赢了数十万英镑，他却根本没有播放设备。你接下来要听的是罗南为爱尔兰电台制作的关于这个人的故事。这个人叫罗杰·多兹。
When I got to Roger's house to watch the tape of his appearance, he didn't have a VCR. We had to go back to the radio station to watch it.
当我到罗杰家看他参加节目的录像时，他没有录像机。我们不得不回到广播电台去看。
Roger Dowds from Dublin.
来自都柏林的罗杰·多兹。
January 2001.
2001年1月。
Were you told to wave?
有人让你挥手吗？
Oh, yes. They made a big issue about waving and smiling and looking as happy as possible.
哦，是的。他们特别强调要挥手、微笑，并尽可能看起来快乐。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] from Dublin.
[听不清]来自都柏林。
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
And it's Fastest Finger first. Stand by your keypads, please.
现在是“最快手指”环节。请准备好你们的键盘。
He was a contestant on the quiz show, Who Wants to Be a Millionaire . I should have put the word "unlikely" in there. Roger was an unlikely contestant, and you'll find out why as the program unfolds.
他是智力竞赛节目《谁想成为百万富翁》的参赛者。我本该加上“不可思议的”这个词。罗杰是一位不可思议的参赛者，随着节目的进行，你会发现原因。
Silence in the studio, please. This is your question. Starting with the largest, arrange these Mediterranean islands in order of size, starting with the largest.
请演播室保持安静。这是你们的问题。从最大开始，按大小排列这些地中海岛屿，从最大的开始。
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
Crete, Cyprus, Sicily, Malta.
克里特岛、塞浦路斯岛、西西里岛、马耳他岛。
Well, there was a phone number you could ring on RTE, obviously. And I rang many times, anyway, with no luck. And eventually, I got a call from someone to say I'd been short-listed. It was a couple of days before the show. You know, they said, oh, you're allowed to have five Phone-a-Friends.
嗯，RTE有个电话号码可以打，显而易见。反正我打了很多次，没中。最后，有人打电话给我说我进入了入围名单。那是在节目开始前几天。你知道，他们说，噢，你可以有五个场外求助人。
I don't have many close friends, so I got two of my brothers. I got someone I play table tennis with. I got the husband of someone I play badminton with, a friend of my brother's, I think. They were the five.
我没什么亲密朋友，所以找了两个兄弟。找了一个跟我一起打乒乓球的人。找了跟我一起打羽毛球的人的丈夫，还有一个是我兄弟的朋友，我想。就是这五个。
And who got there quickest? Two right answers. But Roger Dowds beat it at 4.9 seconds. 4.9 seconds. Well done, Roger. There you go.
谁最快？两个正确答案。但罗杰·多兹以4.9秒的速度胜出。4.9秒。干得好，罗杰。给你。
You know, I wasn't one of these so-called professional quiz people. I'm not an outgoing enough person to be like that, really. People were astounded that I would think of going on Who Wants to Be a Millionaire .
你知道，我不是那种所谓的职业测验选手。我这人不够外向，真的。人们对我想去参加《谁想成为百万富翁》感到震惊。
Now ladies and gentlemen, our next contestant is Roger Dowds. He works as a maintenance assistant in a nursing home. And he lives in Glasnevin in Dublin. And he specifically wants me to mention that his mother, Nora, is deceased, but would be very proud, indeed, to see him on this show.
女士们先生们，下一位参赛者是罗杰·多兹。他在一家疗养院做护理助理。住在都柏林的格拉斯内文。他特别让我提一下，他的母亲诺拉已经去世了，但如果能看到他参加这个节目，她一定会感到非常自豪。
Why did you say that?
你为什么要说这个？
Well, I still was getting over my mother's death somewhat at the time. She was about three years' dead at the time. And she had been such a part of my life. She probably was quite concerned about my future when she died.
嗯，当时我还在努力从母亲去世的阴影中走出来。她去世大概三年了。她是我生命中如此重要的一部分。她在去世时可能很担心我的未来。
And if he won GBP 1 million, he says, he'd help the residents of the nursing home where he works to buy a place and run it however they please. And then he would love to have enough money--
他说，如果赢了100万英镑，他会帮助疗养院的居民买个地方，随心所欲地经营。然后他会希望能有足够的钱——
You know, because you don't really believe you're going to be on, and you go through a lot of questions, what you might say in a circumstance, and I kind of said something very frivolous, expecting not to ever be saying anything.
你知道，因为你根本不相信自己会入选，你会在那种情况下想很多问题，可能会说什么，我当时随口说了些非常轻率的话，完全没想到真的会说出口。
All right, good luck to you. Let's play Who Wants to Be a Millionaire .
好的，祝你好运。让我们开始《谁想成为百万富翁》。
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And for GBP 100, answer this one, Roger. In the 1968 cartoon, what was the color of the Beatles' submarine? Was it blue, yellow, green, or red?
为了100英镑，回答这个问题，罗杰。在1968年的动画片中，甲壳虫乐队的潜水艇是什么颜色的？是蓝色、黄色、绿色还是红色？
Yellow. OK.
黄色。好的。
For GBP 100, yellow is right. You've got GBP 100, Roger.
为了100英镑，黄色是正确的。你赢了100英镑，罗杰。
Financially, how were things at the time? Was that an interest for you?
财务上，当时情况如何？这对你来说是个考虑因素吗？
Yes, it was a factor. I never had full-time employment ever in my life. I was at the time working in this home. But I was only working part-time. And I might have done the odd little odd job, but I was on an extremely low income. So I suppose the money aspect could be significant to me and my position.
是的，是个因素。我这辈子从未有过全职工作。我当时在那家养老院工作。但只是兼职。我可能做过一些零工，但我收入极低。所以我想金钱方面对我来说意义重大。
It's not the other name. So Bill.
那不是另一个名字。所以，比尔。
Bill?
比尔？
That's my answer.
那是我的答案。
For GBP 500?
为了500英镑？
Yeah.
是的。
You've got it. It's the Bill. GBP 500.
你答对了。比尔。500英镑。
Did you practice first?
你练习过吗？
No, there wasn't time to practice. I didn't practice at all. I remember going in the day, and there were all the other contestants. And some of them were poring over quiz books. I just was trying to cope with being there. They made a tremendous day out of it. You were kind of treated like royalty. We were chauffeur-driven in. I think we got a very special lunch that no one else in RTE was getting.
不，没时间练习。我根本没练。我记得去的那天，其他选手都在。有些人正在埋头苦读智力题库。我只是努力让自己适应待在那儿。他们把那天办得很隆重。我们像皇室成员一样受到款待。我们是坐专车进去的。我想我们吃了RTE其他人没吃到的特别午餐。
And I remember thinking, oh, something different is happening today, because I saw some of the people that I recognize who were actors in Fair City. And, I don't know, one or two-- someone who's in Sport in RTE, in addition to all these people. And I don't know whether I'm starstruck or not.
我记得当时想，噢，今天发生了不寻常的事，因为我看到了一些我认出来的演员，他们演过《Fair City》。还有，不知道，一两个——有人是RTE体育频道的，除了所有这些人。我不知道自己是不是被明星光环震住了。
No doubt about that one. You have GBP 1,000. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is the right answer.
毫无疑问。你有1000英镑。[听不清]是正确答案。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
Now, you can never sit in the chair where Roger is sitting if you don't take those telephone numbers. They're 1550-717171 [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
现在，如果你不拨打那些电话号码，你就永远无法坐在罗杰坐的那把椅子上。号码是1550-717171[听不清]。
I'll remember that phone number for the rest of my life.
我会终生记住那个电话号码。
Do you want to tell the audience what happened to you in Morocco, Roger?
你想告诉观众你在摩洛哥发生了什么吗，罗杰？
Well, I--
嗯，我——
Well, no I don't. You're going to make me, anyway.
好吧，我不想。反正你都要让我说。
I was there last month, in fact, in December--
事实上，我上个月，也就是十二月，就在那儿——
I didn't really want to be distracted by anecdotes.
我真的不想被轶事分散注意力。
Moroccan dirham, as they call the currency there. So being a bit shy and retiring, I wanted to get rid of them. And all I could find was an Irish--
摩洛哥迪拉姆，他们那儿叫那种货币。所以因为有点害羞和内向，我想把它们处理掉。我能找到的只有爱尔兰——
Where does this sensitivity come from, this lack of confidence come from?
这种敏感、这种缺乏自信是从哪儿来的？
I'm still trying to work that one out. Well, I was uncommonly close my mother. And I was reluctant to go out into the world and do things as a result. I was almost reclusive in kind of a way, because I didn't go out. I did go to college for a while, and it didn't work out.
我还在努力弄清楚这个问题。嗯，我和我母亲异常亲近。结果我不太愿意进入社会去做事。我几乎是以一种隐居的方式生活，因为我不出去。我有过一段时间去上大学，但没成功。
This is in your early 20s?
这是你20岁出头的时候？
Yeah, I was about 21 at the time.
是的，当时我大约21岁。
GAA fan, are you?
你是盖尔运动协会（GAA）的粉丝吗？
Actually not particularly, but I had that answer before the counties came up. So I think I--
事实上并没有特别喜欢，但在郡名出来之前我就知道答案了。所以我认为我——
You're going with that?
你决定选那个？
--have to go with that.
——必须选那个。
Final answer, Kildare?
最终答案，基尔代尔？
Final answer.
最终答案。
And it makes you worth GBP 8,000, Roger.
这让你赢得了8000英镑，罗杰。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
My father, I suppose, was a little distant from us. It was hard to get any sense of what he expected from us. I sort of feel, in some ways, he was a bit childlike, so sometimes I felt I was fighting for my mother's affection with him. And we had this kind of slightly niggly, sort of relationship as a result. I suppose we were all a bit on our own little wavelength. I was so much younger than the rest, so I think that separated me a bit.
我想我父亲和我们之间有点疏离。很难知道他从我们身上期待什么。我觉得在某些方面，他有点像孩子，所以有时我觉得自己在和他争夺母亲的爱。结果我们之间有一种略带摩擦的关系。我想我们都有点在各自的频道上。我比其他人小得多，所以我觉得那让我有点疏远。
I feel as it's a historical question, now I have a brother who's-- he is a bit of a historian. He studied history. So I think maybe I should phone him. It's my brother, Robert.
我觉得这是一个历史问题，现在我有位兄弟——他算个历史爱好者。他学过历史。所以我想也许我该打电话给他。是我兄弟，罗伯特。
Your brother Robert. OK. Robert.
你兄弟罗伯特。好的。罗伯特。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello.
你好。
Hello, Robert.
你好，罗伯特。
Yes, hello.
是的，你好。
Good evening to you. This is Gay Byrne on Who Wants to Be a Millionaire.
晚上好。我是《谁想成为百万富翁》的盖·伯恩。
Hello.
你好。
And your brother Roger has made it to the hot seat. And he needs your help in answering a question, all right?
你兄弟罗杰已经进入了热座。他需要你的帮助来回答一个问题，好吗？
Thanks very much.
非常感谢。
There are four possible answers to this question. The next voice you hear will be his. And Roger, you have 30 seconds, starting now.
这个问题有四个可能的答案。你接下来听到的声音就是他的。罗杰，你有30秒时间，现在开始。
Robert, where did the Asgard land guns for the Irish Volunteers in July 1914? Was it Banna Strand, Scarriff, Howth, or Arklow?
罗伯特，1914年7月，阿斯加德号在何处为爱尔兰志愿军运送了武器？是班纳海滩、斯卡里夫、霍斯，还是阿克洛？
Howth.
霍斯。
Thank you very much. You're sure about that?
非常感谢。你确定吗？
About 95%.
95%左右。
I thought it might be that myself. So thank you.
我自己也想可能是那个。所以谢谢你。
OK. Bye.
好的。再见。
Thank you very much. Bye. I'll go with that. Howth.
非常感谢。再见。我就选那个了。霍斯。
Howth, final answer?
霍斯，最终答案？
Final answer.
最终答案。
Could Roger be right in saying Howth for the answer? We'll take a break here. Come back to us after this. Thank you.
罗杰说霍斯是对的吗？我们休息一下。广告后见。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
Can you remember the day you decided that college wasn't for you or that college wasn't working out?
你还记得那天你决定大学不适合你，或者大学进展不顺利的时候吗？
Oh, I didn't feel part of anything there. And I had all sorts of essays and assignments that I was supposed to have done. And I hadn't started on anything. And just one day, I didn't go in. I was so lacking in resources to deal with things then that I couldn't tell anyone. I actually pretended for a whole term to go to college. I spent most of the days like a homeless person, walking around town. Whatever I did. I brought in my sandwiches just as I normally had done. And my brother, in particular, was trying to get me to go back. But it just didn't seem possible. It was simple as that.
噢，我觉得我在那儿不属于任何群体。我本该完成的所有论文和作业，我一项都没开始。有一天，我就没去学校。当时我缺乏处理问题的资源，以至于我没法告诉任何人。我甚至假装上了一个学期的大学。我大部分时间都像个无家可归的人，在城里晃荡。无论我做什么。我像往常一样带上三明治。我的兄弟特别试图让我回去。但这似乎根本不可能。就这么简单。
The question was, where did the Asgard land guns for the Irish Volunteers in July 1914? He had to check with his brother, Robert. Robert said Howth. He went with Howth. That was his final answer. And it means he's worth GBP 16,000.
问题是，1914年7月阿斯加德号在何处为爱尔兰志愿军运送武器？他不得不咨询他的兄弟罗伯特。罗伯特说是霍斯。他选了霍斯。那是他的最终答案。这意味着他赢得了16000英镑。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
The next question is worth GBP 32,000, Roger. OK. Have a look at it. Who was the first person to run a mile in under four minutes?
下一个问题价值32000英镑，罗杰。好的。看一眼。谁是第一个在四分钟内跑完一英里的人？
I couldn't believe my luck with this question.
我简直不敢相信我的运气能遇到这个问题。
Sebastian Coe, Harold Abrahams--
塞巴斯蒂安·科，哈罗德·亚伯拉罕——
You're shaking your head.
你在摇头。
Yeah, because I'm going to know it before I see any answers.
是的，因为在看到答案之前我就知道它了。
Well, I think you arranged this question for me, because it just happens it's my namesake, Roger Bannister. I've always had an interest in athletics. And I'm quite sure about this one. Roger Bannister. 1954, I believe it was.
嗯，我想你一定是为我安排了这个题目，因为碰巧那是我的同名者，罗杰·班尼斯特。我一直对田径运动很感兴趣。而且我很确定这个答案。罗杰·班尼斯特。我相信是1954年。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Roger, don't confuse me with dates.
罗杰，别用日期来困扰我。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
I felt I should be offering more information.
我觉得我本应该提供更多信息。
Whatever about the angels, Roger. I think mama's looking after you as well, is she? Because you've just won GBP 32,000.
不管天使的事了，罗杰。我想妈妈也在保佑你吧？因为你刚刚赢了32000英镑。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
The crowd seemed to get particularly enthusiastic at that point.
在那一刻，观众们似乎特别热情。
They must have all those checks written out, do they?
他们一定准备好支票了吧？
Oh, yes. Yeah, yeah. There's no writing involved.
噢，是的。是的，不需要亲笔写。
GBP 32,000. And you get to keep that. Nobody can take that from you.
32000英镑。你可以保留。没人能从你这儿拿走。
No matter what.
无论如何。
No matter what, that's yours, OK? And you're right. Bannister did run the mile in 1954, not that we asked you.
无论如何，那都是你的，明白吗？而且你是对的。班尼斯特确实在1954年跑完了一英里，虽然我们没问你日期。
Did your mother encourage you to go out into the world?
你母亲鼓励你进入社会吗？
She did try to encourage me when I left college. She was always looking at courses that I might do. Because I used to do the garden at home or I did a bit of cooking at home, oh, will you do a cookery course? Will you do a gardening course? You know, just to see me doing something.
我离开大学时她确实鼓励过我。她总是寻找我可能会参加的课程。因为我以前在家里打理花园或做点饭，噢，你要不要参加烹饪课程？要不要参加园艺课程？你知道，就是想看我做点什么。
But then I gradually-- as my parents got older, they started becoming infirm. And I did become more of a benefit, because I just became their chauffeur and stuff like that.
但后来我逐渐——随着父母变老，他们身体开始虚弱，我确实变得更有用了，因为我成了他们的司机之类的人。
Was it a time you felt good about yourself?
那是你自我感觉良好的时光吗？
I think I felt better that I had some little sense of duty in doing something. Because when I was first at home and my parents were still a bit active, I remember, literally, sometimes that people came in during the day and maybe they thought I should be out. And I'd actually literally hide under the bed-- a grown man in his 20s-- just to avoid having to explain myself.
我觉得我对自己有点责任感，这让我感觉好些。因为当我刚待在家里、父母还活跃的时候，我记得，真的，有时白天有人进来，他们可能认为我应该出去。我真的会躲在床底下——一个20多岁的成年男人——只是为了避免向人解释自己。
That must have made you so angry.
那一定让你感到非常愤怒。
I couldn't express anger. I was such a-- I don't know-- such a-- well, withdrawn from anger. I was angry in some way. But I didn't recognize it as anger. Well, I was so full of self-hatred. I didn't have any sense of self-esteem. So I think because of that I couldn't do things at all.
我没法表达愤怒。我是如此一个——我不知道——如此一个——嗯，远离愤怒的人。我在某种程度上很愤怒。但我没认出那是愤怒。嗯，我充满了自我厌恶。我没有任何自尊。所以我认为因为那个，我根本做不了事。
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
I think I have nothing to lose. I shall go for Venus as my final answer.
我想我没什么可失去的。我决定选“金星”作为最终答案。
That's your final answer?
那是你的最终答案？
Final answer.
最终答案。
Venus, final answer. You had GBP 32,000, Roger. You now have GBP 64,000.
金星，最终答案。你之前有32000英镑，罗杰。你现在有64000英镑。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
The biscuits are from the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] cookery book.
这些饼干是来自[听不清]烹饪书。
Tea and biscuits in Roger's house. The biscuits are on a plate bought by his family to support the Protestant side in the 1957 boycott, where Catholics boycotted Protestant businesses, and Protestants, like Rogers' family, bought things to keep those businesses alive.
罗杰家里的茶和饼干。饼干放在一个盘子里，那是他的家人在1957年抵制运动期间为了支持新教徒一侧而买的，当时天主教徒抵制新教徒的生意，而像罗杰家这样的新教徒则通过购买来维持这些生意。
She compiled a cookery book, which seemed to go all around Protestant communities around Ireland.
她编写了一本烹饪书，似乎在爱尔兰各地的新教社区流传。
Roger felt isolated as a child. And the fact that he was part of a minority community only made that feeling of isolation more intense. But being a Protestant also got him out of the house. He travels miles to play racket sports in clubs that used to be exclusive to his church, something that's no longer the case, and he's glad of that. He goes out to play the organ at church services. And through the church community, he found work in a retirement home set up originally for Protestant residents.
罗杰小时候感到孤独。而他是少数群体社区的一员，使这种孤独感更加强烈。但作为新教徒也让他有机会走出家门。他长途跋涉到以前曾是他教会专属的俱乐部去参加球拍运动，现在情况不再是那样了，他对此感到高兴。他出去在教堂礼拜中弹奏管风琴。通过教会社区，他在一家最初为新教居民建立的养老院找到了工作。
I mean, it has been a tremendous experience over the years. I met some very special people who have passed away because they were old. Well, my mother died at the end of 1997. And shortly after that a woman called Joyce [? Schultheis ?] came into the home. And she just was a tremendous-- excuse me crying-- but gift to me at the time.
我的意思是，这些年来这是一次极其美妙的经历。我遇到了一些非常特别的人，他们因为年老而去世了。嗯，我母亲在1997年底去世了。在那之后不久，一个叫乔伊斯[听不清]的女人进了养老院。她对我当时来说简直是一个——对不起我哭了——但确实是一个礼物。
From the generation she came from, she was a person of rare understanding. You could tell her anything, and she was unshockable. And because of the slightly narrow environment I'd been living in, I felt things had to be kept secret and kind of hidden. Suddenly, I got this different perspective.
从她那一辈人来看，她是一个极其通情达理的人。你可以告诉她任何事，她都镇定自若。由于我生活在稍微狭窄的环境中，我觉得事情必须保密和隐藏。突然间，我得到了一个不同的视角。
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
I feel very strongly that it's Patrick Kavanagh. I think Louis MacNeice died earlier than 1967. So I'll go for Patrick Kavanagh as my final answer.
我强烈觉得是帕特里克·卡瓦纳。我想路易斯·麦克尼斯去世比1967年更早。所以我选帕特里克·卡瓦纳作为最终答案。
Final answer?
最终答案？
Final answer, Gay.
最终答案，盖。
No turning back.
没有回头路。
We've gone to [? orange. ?] That was one of the most surprising pieces of thinking I've seen on this show so far. And it's won you GBP 100,000.
我们转向了[听不清]。这是我在这个节目中见过的最令人惊讶的思维过程之一。它为你赢得了100000英镑。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Around the time I was on Who Wants to Be a Millionare, I started going to a counselor, who I'm still going to. I think she's helped with sort of relieving me after the awful self-hatred.
在我参加《谁想成为百万富翁》的时候，我开始去看心理医生，我现在还在看。我想她帮助我缓解了可怕的自我厌恶。
Why did you decide you needed her?
你为什么决定你需要她？
I got very friendly with quite an elderly man. And as I said, it was the summer just before I went to school. Oh, sorry, college. And I used to go and visit him. And unfortunately, he started abusing me. And although I was 18, I suppose I was 12. I hadn't had sex education of any kind.
我和一位相当老的人变得非常亲近。就像我说的，那是我上学校之前的那个夏天。噢，抱歉，大学。我经常去拜访他。不幸的是，他开始虐待我。尽管我18岁了，我猜我只有12岁。我没有接受过任何形式的性教育。
I didn't really consent to anything, but I allowed this to happen for about a year, I don't know, because I suppose in some way I valued his attention. And finally-- because I'd never not confided in my mother-- so I did eventually confide in her about this. And it was a very difficult thing for her. She was used to kind of sweeping things aside, putting them under the carpet. I lost a little bit of something with my mother that day.
我并没有真的同意任何事，但我让这件事发生了一年，我不知道，因为我猜在某种程度上我重视他的关注。最后——因为我从未没对我母亲吐露过——所以我最终还是向她吐露了这件事。这对她来说是一件非常困难的事。她习惯于把事情扫到一边，藏在地毯下。那天我和我母亲之间丢失了一点东西。
I'm sorry. I missed that. You what?
抱歉。我没听清。你什么？
I kind of lost a little bit of something with my mother. I idealized her so much. And she was so wonderful.
我和我母亲之间丢失了一点东西。我太理想化她了。她是那么好。
And did you go back to the elderly man?
你回到那个老人家了吗？
I went once. But I didn't-- I remember going once to the door and talking to him. And I made up some outlandish story and, well, lies. So as a result of that, he kind of didn't want to have anything more to do with me anyway. I suppose I pretended I'd gone off with someone else.
我回去过一次。但我没有——我记得我回去过一次到门口和他交谈。我编造了一些离奇的故事，嗯，谎言。结果，他反正也不想再和我有什么牵扯了。我想我假装我已经和别人走了。
Did he think there was something else in what you were doing?
他认为你所做的有别的内容吗？
How do you mean? Sorry.
你是什么意思？抱歉。
Well, did he see it in the same way as you did? Or did he see it as something else? Did he see it as abuse? Or did he see it as a relationship?
嗯，他和你从同样的视角看待它吗？还是他将其视为别的东西？他将其视为虐待吗？还是将其视为一段关系？
No, he probably saw it as a relationship or something. I don't think he would have had any sense of the abuse I was feeling. At that point, I think I could have let anyone do anything to me. I had so little self-esteem, I suppose I couldn't-- It's like as if I became mute, and I couldn't shout stop.
不，他可能将其视为一段关系或其他什么。我不认为他会对所感受到的虐待有任何感觉。在那一刻，我想我可以让任何人对我做任何事。我的自尊心太低了，我想我不能——就好像我变得哑巴了，我无法大喊“停”。
[GAME SHOW MUSIC]
[游戏节目音乐]
I'm very sure I know this one, Gay.
我非常肯定我知道这个，盖。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I couldn't believe the audience's response. I thought they were going to collapse.
我简直不敢相信观众的反应。我还以为他们要崩溃了。
They're really behind you.
他们真的在支持你。
Yeah, yeah, extraordinarily so.
是的，是的，非常特别。
I explained the situation earlier, Roger.
我之前解释过情况，罗杰。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You have GBP 125,000. You walk now, there's the check. I have it. You could walk now with that. If you go for this and get it wrong, you lose GBP 93,000.
你有125000英镑。你现在走，支票就在这。我拿着呢。你现在可以带着那笔钱走。如果你继续下去但答错了，你将失去93000英镑。
That's a bit drastic, all right.
那确实有点极端。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yes.
是的。
But I do know a bit about birds. And that is my final answer, Gay.
但我确实对鸟类有些了解。这是我的最终答案，盖。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Final answer.
最终答案。
You had GBP 125,000, Roger. You now have GBP 250,000.
你之前有125000英镑，罗杰。你现在有250000英镑。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
The whole audience had won it, themselves.
整个观众席他们自己也赢了。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Imagine having to take home a cartload of money.
想象一下不得不带走一车钱回家。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
I want to shed a few tears now.
我现在想掉几滴眼泪。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All that was going through my head was that Gay Byrne, himself, had lost a lot of money.
我脑子里想的只有盖·伯恩本人输了很多钱。
Don't start crying on me at this stage.
别在这阶段跟我哭。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The next question is worth half a million pounds.
下一个问题价值50万英镑。
I don't feel I want to look at it, actually.
事实上，我觉得我不想看它。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Look at it.
看一眼。
Now, what did you think of that?
现在，你觉得那个怎么样？
What does a vexillologist study?
旗帜学家研究什么？
I didn't think much.
我没多想。
A vexillologist study? Is it--
旗帜学家研究？是——
I think my brain had seized up. I couldn't come up with anything.
我想我的大脑罢工了。我什么也想不出来。
--flags, or skin diseases? Vexillologist. And if you look at me and say, funnily enough, Gay, I know the answer--
——旗帜，还是皮肤病？旗帜学家。如果你看着我说，真有趣，盖，我知道答案——
Funnily enough, I know the answer--
真有趣，我知道答案——
You were fairly entertaining, weren't you?
你相当有趣，不是吗？
Yeah, I was surprised how many people thought I was entertaining.
是的，我很惊讶有多少人认为我很有趣。
No, I'll have to be quite honest to you.
不，我得诚实地告诉你。
Were you disappointed you hadn't got an easy one?
你是否因为没遇到简单的题而失望？
Well, I couldn't believe my luck up to that. I was carried on in the tide of wanting to keep going, just not even to do with the money, just I was enjoying being up there in some way. So I didn't want to stop.
嗯，我简直不敢相信我的运气能走到那一步。我沉浸在想继续前进的潮水里，甚至跟钱无关，只是我以某种方式享受待在那儿。所以我不想停。
GBP 18,000. ?]
18000英镑。[听不清]？
What's the word? I shall retire now, or whatever I should say.
那个词是什么？我现在要退出了，或者无论我该说什么。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
To get all this positive feedback from other people was extraordinary, to feel I was worth something and people could admire me.
能从其他人那里得到所有这些积极的反馈太不寻常了，感觉到我是有价值的，人们会钦佩我。
It says, pay Roger Dowds GBP 250,000. Take it with our blessing and our thanks. You've been a lovely, lovely competitor and played extremely well. You deserve it.
它上面写着，支付罗杰·多兹250000英镑。带着我们的祝福和感谢拿走它。你是一位可爱、可爱的竞争者，表现得非常出色。你应得的。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
Enjoy.
享受吧。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Enjoy your [INAUDIBLE].
享受你的[听不清]。
And did friends and family deal differently with you afterwards?
后来朋友和家人对待你的方式有不同吗？
Not enormously. Well, I think they admired me for having done it. I'm the youngest of my family, and I think maybe I was always seen as very vulnerable or sensitive. And maybe they felt the less reason to be worried about my future.
没太大不同。嗯，我想他们钦佩我做到了这件事。我是家里最小的，我想也许我一直被视为非常脆弱或敏感。也许他们觉得为我的未来担心没必要了。
So what has that future been for Roger? What did he do with the hundreds of thousands? Well, he uses it as an income to supplement part-time work gardening and house minding. It also allows him time to visit elderly people and do messages for them.
那么罗杰的未来是什么样的？他用那几十万做了什么？嗯，他用它作为收入来补充园艺和看房的兼职工作。这也让他有时间去拜访老人并为他们跑腿。
I was persuaded that I absolutely had to get an alarm for the house. I went on a nice, organized cycling holiday in France, I remember. And I went skiing. I'd never been skiing.
有人劝我说我绝对得给房子安个警报器。我记得我在法国度过了一个不错的、有组织的自行车假期。我还去滑雪了。我从没滑过雪。
The main thing Roger got from Who Wants to Be a Millionaire wasn't the money. It was self-confidence.
罗杰从《谁想成为百万富翁》中得到的最大的东西不是钱。是自信。
Well, I think I'm a lot less shy than I was, perhaps. I have more sense of well being within myself. I don't have the awful self-hatred.
嗯，我想我比以前没那么害羞了，也许。我内心有更多的幸福感。我不再有可怕的自我厌恶。
[ORGAN PLAYING]
[管风琴演奏]
In his modest house with his very modest car outside, Roger has one luxury to show for his night on the tele with Gay, a piano organ.
在他朴素的房子外面停着那辆非常朴素的车，罗杰展现出了他与盖在电视上那晚的一个奢侈品：一台钢琴风琴。
Ronan Kelly's story about Roger Dowds, from the Irish radio program, Flux on RTE Radio 1. It was a winner of the Third Coast International Audio Competition, which is where we heard of it. Since this show aired, Roger Dowds has picked up another award. He won a gold medal for Ireland in tennis at the Outgames, a competition of gay and lesbian athletes in Montreal.
罗南·凯利关于罗杰·多兹的故事，来自RTE第一电台的《Flux》广播节目。它是第三海岸国际音频竞赛的获奖者，这也是我们听到它的地方。自节目播出以来，罗杰·多兹又获得了一个奖项。他在蒙特利尔的同性恋和女同性恋运动员竞赛“Outgames”中获得了爱尔兰网球金牌。
Coming up, can quiz shows save the world? One woman believed yes. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，智力竞赛节目能拯救世界吗？一位女性相信可以。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续。
[MUSIC - "REFLEXOS" BY LUIZ ECA]
[音乐 - 路易斯·埃卡的《Reflexos》]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our program we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Secret Life of Quiz Shows. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Dire Enigmas For Elite Fans.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为你带来关于该主题的各种不同类型的报道。今天的节目是《智力竞赛节目的秘密生活》。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，精英粉丝的难题。
Every winter, there is this event at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology, where some of the country's very best puzzle solvers go up against the very best puzzle writers. It's called the MIT Mystery Hunt. And what it is is a series of puzzles-- word puzzles, number puzzles, scavenger hunts, picture puzzles, puzzles which don't even have a name.
每年冬天，在麻省理工学院都会举行一场活动，该国最优秀的解谜者会对抗最优秀的谜题作者。这叫麻省理工神秘大搜捕。它是一系列谜题——文字谜题、数字谜题、寻宝游戏、图片谜题，甚至没有名字的谜题。
And eventually what all this leads to-- this takes all weekend or longer-- what it leads to, the final answer, it leads you to a coin hidden somewhere on the MIT campus. This is a team competition. The teams are made up of MIT students, and also elite puzzle solvers who fly in from around the country for the event.
最终所有这些通向——这需要整个周末或更长时间——最终答案会把你引向藏在麻省理工校园某处的硬币。这是一场团队竞赛。团队由麻省理工学生组成，还有从全国各地飞来参加活动的精英解谜者。
One of our producers, Lisa Pollak, joined them for last year's contest. She was following a team called Dr. Awkward. And for those of you who are playing along at home, Dr. Awkward is spelled, D-R period Awkward, A-W-K-W-A-R-D. Give yourself two points if you noticed that that is a palindrome, spelled the same forwards and backwards. Here's Lisa.
我们的制作人之一，丽莎·波拉克，去年加入了他们。她跟随了一支叫“奥克沃德博士”的团队。对于那些在家玩的人，奥克沃德博士拼写为：D-R点奥克沃德，A-W-K-W-A-R-D。如果你注意到这是一个回文（正着念反着念都一样），给自己加两分。这是丽莎。
When you hang out with a puzzle team, you hear a lot of stories like Dave Dickerson's. When Dave was just a kid, he got this book. He'll never forget the title.
当你和谜题团队待在一起时，你会听到很多像戴夫·迪克森这样的故事。戴夫还是个孩子时，得到了这本书。他永远不会忘记那个标题。
Puzzles , Puzzles , Puzzles, Puzzles, Puzzles.
谜题，谜题，谜题，谜题，谜题。
Actually, the title might have just been Puzzles, but that's what the cover said. Dave was obsessed with this book. The puzzles were harder than any he'd ever seen, but he couldn't put them down.
其实标题可能只是《谜题》，但封面就是那么写的。戴夫沉迷于这本书。谜题比他见过任何题目都难，但他停不下来。
And I even remember when I saw one of the clues-- not an elegant clue by modern standards-- but it said, damn, I'm trying to fix these socks. And the answer was darn. The darn socks. You know, needle and thread. And I thought, I get that. And I solved it. It was the first clue I had actually solved. And I thought, I can do this. I had never been challenged this much in my life. And I didn't realize I could do it.
我甚至记得看到其中一个线索时——按照现代标准不算优雅——但它写着：该死，我正在尝试修理这些袜子。答案是“补”。补袜子。你知道，针和线。我想，我懂了。我就解决了。这是我第一个真正解开的线索。我想，我能做到。我一生中从没受到过如此大的挑战。我没意识到我能做到。
Not only could Dave do it, he found it impossible to stop doing it, which is how, almost 30 years later, he ended up here, standing in an MIT classroom with the rest of the Dr. Awkward team, warming up for the mystery hunt. And by warming up, I mean they were plugging in their laptops and setting up a snack table.
戴夫不仅做到了，而且发现根本停不下来，这就是为什么将近30年后，他最终站在麻省理工学院的一间教室里，和“奥克沃德博士”团队的其他成员一起，为神秘大搜捕热身。所谓热身，就是他们插上笔记本电脑，摆好零食桌。
This was an experienced team with about 45 people on the roster. And as far as brainpower goes, they were an intimidating crew-- crossword champs, PhDs, a guy handing out DVDs of his recent appearance on Jeopardy, two guys whose T-shirts I needed help deciphering, and this man, whose nickname I'm still trying to figure out.
这是一支经验丰富的团队，名单上有45人左右。就脑力而言，他们是一群令人生畏的家伙——填字游戏冠军、博士、一个正在分发他最近参加《危险边缘》DVD的人、两个我需要翻译T恤上文字的家伙，还有这个人，我还在试着找出他的绰号。
Ucaoimhu, spelled U-C-A-O-I-M-H-U. And it's from my real name, Kevin Wald. You split it up as KEV-IN W-ALD. Ald is an archaic form of the word "old," so you take an old-style "W", which is two "U's." You take "Kev" the way it's in the original Irish spelling, which is C-A-O-I-M-H. And you put it in the two "U's," so you get Ucaoimhu.
Ucaoimhu，拼写为U-C-A-O-I-M-H-U。它是取自我的真名，凯文·沃尔德。你把它拆开为KEV-IN W-ALD。Ald是单词“old”（老）的古语形式，所以你取一个古式的“W”，也就是两个“U”。你取爱尔兰原始拼写方式中的“Kev”，即C-A-O-I-M-H。把它放进两个“U”里，你就得到了Ucaoimhu。
We're definitely a dangerous team. There's no question about it.
我们绝对是一支危险的团队。毫无疑问。
That's Dave again. He's the person who invited me to hang out here. And he warned me that the puzzles I'd see his team solve that weekend wouldn't be what most of us imagine when we think of puzzles. Mystery hunt puzzles are so elaborate, so complex, that lots of times they don't even have instructions, just a page of words or pictures or numbers arranged in some cryptic way, which means you've often got to solve a puzzle just to know what puzzle you're trying to solve.
又是戴夫。他是邀请我来这里的人。他警告我，那个周末我看到的谜题与我们大多数人想到谜题时所想象的不一样。神秘大搜捕的谜题如此精致、如此复杂，以至于很多时候它们甚至没有指令，只是一页以某种神秘方式排列的文字、图片或数字，这意味着你通常必须先解开一个谜题，才知道你正在试图解开什么谜题。
So for example, the first puzzle hunt-- or maybe one of the first-- the guy who did it did a puzzle in Linear A, which is an old language. I think it's older than Greek, a very, very primitive, ancient language. And he didn't tell anyone it was Linear A. And he took the only two books on Linear A out of the MIT library. People solved it anyway.
举个例子，第一个搜捕活动——或者最早的之一——做这个的人做了一个用线性文字A写的谜题，那是一种古老的语言。我想它比希腊语还古老，一种非常、非常原始的古代语言。他没告诉任何人那是线性文字A。而且他从麻省理工图书馆借走了仅有的两本关于线性文字A的书。人们还是把它解开了。
Hey, everybody!
嘿，大家！
[CHEERS]
[欢呼]
How you doing today?
今天过得怎么样？
[CHEERS]
[欢呼]
That's right.
没错。
The mystery hunt started with an opening ceremony put on by last year's winning team. They're called The Evil Midnight Bombers What Bomb At Midnight. That's the way the hunt works. The group that won last year's hunt designs and runs this year's contest. Dozens of teams pack the lobby of an MIT building. And though they were competing, from what I could tell the mood seemed pretty friendly. The Evil Midnight Bombers kicked things off with a skit. Then all the teams headed off to various locations around campus, and the solving began.
神秘大搜捕以去年的获胜团队举办的开幕式开始。他们叫“午夜爆炸的邪恶午夜轰炸机”。活动就是这样运作的。去年赢得搜捕活动的团体负责设计并运作今年的竞赛。几十支队伍挤在麻省理工的一栋大楼大厅里。尽管他们在竞争，但从我所见来看，气氛似乎相当友好。“邪恶午夜轰炸机”以一个小品开始了活动。然后所有队伍前往校园各处，解谜活动开始了。
[CHALK ON A CHALKBOARD]
[粉笔在黑板上写的声响]
So what do you do with FNTLLLLLLSNN?
那么你用FNTLLLLLLSNN做什么？
Those ?] just might be an index to something else. It might not even be an index to something in this round.
那些[听不清]可能只是指向别的东西的索引。它甚至可能不是这一轮里某个东西的索引。
That's Jeremy and [? Tripp, ?] two Dr. Awkward teammates, standing at a blackboard a few hours into the hunt. Now I'll be honest, as a spectator sport, competitive puzzle solving has some problems. Most of the time there wasn't much to see, just people huddled in small groups around laptops and conferring over printouts, batting around one idea after another until they hit on an answer.
那是杰里米和[听不清]，两名奥克沃德博士队友，在搜捕开始几小时后站在黑板前。说实话，作为一项观赏性运动，竞技解谜有一些问题。大多数时候没啥可看的，只是一群人围着笔记本电脑挤在一起，对着打印稿商量，一个接一个地推敲想法，直到他们找到答案。
The third one is Gilligan's Island. Who's writing this down?
第三个是《吉利根岛》。谁记下来了？
Things seemed to be going pretty well. The blackboard was filling up with answers and new puzzles kept coming. But there were some stumpers, too.
事情似乎进展得相当顺利。黑板上填满了答案，新的谜题不断出现。但也有一些让人卡住的题。
And that doesn't look promising. So look at last letters.
那看起来不太有希望。看看最后一个字母。
SAX?
SAX？
The name of this puzzle was Continental Divide. It was one of those no-instruction puzzles. There was a sheet of paper with a bunch of pictures of DVD movie covers on it. And the covers were arranged in a grid, six boxes across and five down. The bottom right-hand box was empty. All the titles on the covers were blacked out. Finding those was the easy part. It turns out all the films had a city, state, or country in the name. Raising Arizona , Road to Singapore , The Tailor of Panama . And so on.
这个谜题的名字叫“大陆分界线”。它是那种没有指令的谜题之一。有一张纸，上面有一堆电影DVD封面的图片。封面排列成一个网格，横着六个格子，竖着五个。右下角的格子是空的。所有封面的标题都被抹黑了。找到那些标题是简单部分。结果所有电影名称里都有城市、州或国家。《挺进亚利桑那》、《通往新加坡之路》、《巴拿马裁缝》。等等。
The answer, everyone agreed, had something to do with those place names, but what? Were they trying to put a title in the missing box? Spell a sentence from a combination of letters? I watched for more than an hour as at least a dozen different people tried together to figure it out.
每个人都同意答案与那些地名有关，但到底是什么呢？他们是想在缺少的格子里填个标题吗？通过字母组合拼出一个句子吗？我看了超过一个小时，至少有十几个人试着一起弄清楚。
Annapolis, Dallas, Essex, Cancun. All of these in this column do not end in vowels.
安纳波利斯、达拉斯、埃塞克斯、坎昆。这一列里的所有这些都不以元音结尾。
They plotted the names on a map. They typed them into a spreadsheet. They put them in a grid and they color coded them by continent. No pattern was too absurd to consider.
他们把地名画在地图上。他们输入电子表格。他们把它们放在网格里并按大洲进行颜色编码。没有一种模式是荒谬到不考虑的。
Arizona Iced Tea, Singapore sling, Panama hat. I still think we might be able to get drinks out of them.
亚利桑那冰茶、新加坡司令、巴拿马帽。我还是觉得我们可以从它们那里得到饮料名。
India pale ale.
印度淡色艾尔啤酒。
India pale ale and-- OK, yeah. These are drinks across.
印度淡色艾尔啤酒和——好的，没错。这些是横向的饮料名。
Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。
They could not have been more wrong.
他们不可能错得更离谱了。
I like the idea from half an hour ago where we were mapping these things to letters.
我喜欢半小时前关于把这些东西映射到字母上的想法。
The answer ended up having something to do with DVD country codes. But they didn't know that yet. For now, despite all the work, they weren't getting anywhere. At times I couldn't believe they were actually doing this for fun. But for puzzle people, the struggle is part of the fun. It's not in vain, because they know that somewhere out there there's an answer.
答案最后与DVD国家码有关。但他们还不知道。目前，尽管付出了所有努力，他们还是毫无进展。有时我简直不敢相信他们真的把这当成乐趣。但对于玩谜题的人来说，奋斗也是乐趣的一部分。这并非徒劳，因为他们知道在某个地方存在着答案。
I mean, somebody can say something in the next 15 seconds that will just break this whole thing wide open.
我是说，某个人在接下来的15秒内说出的话，就能让这一切豁然开朗。
That's Eric, a veteran of the team. And what he's talking about there, that flash of insight, that aha moment when something suddenly becomes clear, that's the payoff.
那是埃里克，团队老手。他所谈论的那一点灵感，那个突然变得清晰的“啊哈”瞬间，就是回报。
An observation that nobody else saw, seeing through the problem. And that's difficult to do. And I'm not going to do it on every puzzle. I'm not one of the geniuses around here. But I am able to contribute something, and I'm just waiting for that to happen.
别人没看到的观察，看穿问题。这很难做到。我不会在每个谜题上都做到这一点。我不是这儿的天才。但我能贡献一些东西，我正在等待那一刻发生。
You don't have to solve a puzzle to have an aha moment. The puzzles, if you're a puzzle person, are a pretty reliable way to get them, as opposed to real life, where, as a team member named John pointed out to me, most problems don't come with their own answers.
你不必解开谜题才能有“啊哈”瞬间。如果你是玩谜题的人，谜题是获得那种瞬间相当可靠的方式，这与现实生活不同，正如团队成员约翰向我指出的那样，现实生活中的大多数问题并没有自带答案。
You know, it's very different trying to figure out, why does my daughter hate me? And how can I help her? Because there's no solution to that. Versus, OK, what are those numbers in the background of the evil video? Are they trying to say some message there? This you get the joy of, OK. At least you got the answer, and you know that you got the answer.
你知道，试图弄清楚“为什么我女儿讨厌我？以及我该如何帮助她？”是非常不同的。因为那个没有解决方案。对比，“好的，那个邪恶视频背景里的数字是什么？他们是在试图表达某种信息吗？”这个你能享受到，“好的，至少你得到了答案，你知道你得到了答案。”
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
It is right now 1:23 in the morning. And we're in the sixth round. We've got tons and tons of puzzles in these rounds.
现在是凌晨1:23。我们在第六轮。这些轮次里有成吨的谜题。
When I caught up with Ucaoimhu, the Dr. Awkward team had been solving puzzles for 13 and 1/2 straight hours. The desks were covered with empty food containers. And the classroom was starting to smell like a dorm room whose residents hadn't showered in a while. Some team members had gone home to sleep. And a night crew with fresher brains had shown up to relieve them. But Ucaoimhu, like a lot of the 20 or so people here, had been there since the start.
当我追上Ucaoimhu时，奥克沃德博士团队已经连续解谜13个半小时了。书桌上覆盖着空的食品盒。教室开始闻起来像那种住户很久没洗澡的宿舍。一些团队成员回家睡觉了，换了一批头脑更清醒的夜班人员来接替他们。但像这里大约20人中的许多人一样，Ucaoimhu从一开始就在那儿了。
How are you feeling right now?
你现在感觉如何？
Right now, I'm feeling tired. And I'll probably leave within the next hour or so. Fortunately, what I'm working on now is a nice, gentle kind of puzzle.
现在，我觉得累了。我可能会在接下来一小时左右离开。幸运的是，我现在处理的是一种既优雅又温和的谜题。
And by a nice, gentle kind of puzzle, what Ucaoimhu meant was a grid that looked kind of like a crossword puzzle, only with no blacked-in squares, no numbers, and no clues. I repeat, no clues at all, just empty boxes. Oh, and in the background, a red cross, like on an English flag. And yes, they solved it.
所谓既优雅又温和的谜题，Ucaoimhu指的是一个看起来像填字游戏的网格，只是没有填黑的方块，没有数字，也没有线索。我再说一遍，根本没有线索，只有空的方块。噢，背景里有个红十字，就像英国国旗上的一样。是的，他们解开了。
I stuck around that night watching until 6:00 in the morning. And what struck me about the whole scene was how matter of fact everyone was, like there was nothing out of the ordinary here, as if this was the most normal thing in the world, men and women, some college students, but plenty with spouses and kids at home, staying up all night in a college classroom solving puzzles.
那天晚上我一直待到凌晨6点。整个场景让我印象深刻的是每个人表现得多么理所当然，好像这里没发生什么不寻常的事，好像这是世界上最正常的事情：男人和女人，有些是大学生，但有很多在家有配偶和孩子，整晚待在大学教室里解谜。
But the next day, as the hunt stretched into its 30th hour, I caught up with Dave, the guy who invited me here. And he told me that, as a puzzle person, he was constantly being reminded that the rest of the world doesn't work this way. Just the other day, he'd gone into a bar. And when the female bartender came over, he told her about this cool new anagram he'd heard, how if you take the phrase, a dream within a dream, and rearrange the letters, you get, what am I? A mind reader.
但在第二天，当搜捕活动延长到第30小时，我追上了戴夫，那个邀请我来这里的人。他告诉我，作为一名玩谜题的人，他经常被提醒，世界其他地方不是这样运作的。就在前几天，他进了一家酒吧。当女酒保走过来时，他告诉她他听到的一个超酷的新变位词，说如果你取“a dream within a dream”（梦中之梦）这个短语，重新排列字母，你就能得到“what am I? A mind reader”（我是什么？读心者）。
This didn't go over so well. The bartender-- apparently finding this fact neither interesting nor charming-- just looked at Dave like he was weird. Dave told me that years ago, while he was working as a greeting card writer for Hallmark in Kansas City, he actually got in trouble for doing this kind of thing.
这没那么好用。那个酒保——显然觉得这个事实既没趣也不迷人——只是看着戴夫，觉得他很奇怪。戴夫告诉我，几年前，当他在堪萨斯城的霍尔马克做贺卡撰稿人时，他确实因为做这种事惹上了麻烦。
My mentor came to me and said, Dave, we have to talk. And he said, Dave, you're using too many literary allusions in your casual speech and people are complaining.
我的导师来找我说，戴夫，我们得谈谈。他说，戴夫，你在日常谈话中用了太多的文学典故，人们在抱怨。
Wait, wait. In your speech, not in your greeting cards?
等等，等等。是在你的谈话中，而不是在贺卡里？
Right, right, just in my everyday speech. I knew better than to use obscure allusions in greeting cards, goodness gracious. I asked my supervisor, what the hell does that even mean? And he said, I was just told to tell it to you.
对，对，只是在我的日常谈话中。我知道不能在贺卡里用生僻的典故，老天保佑。我问主管，那到底是什么意思？他说，我只是被要求来告诉你的。
Dave started obsessing about this. He wasn't even sure what the problem was, so he began keeping track. One week, every time he had the urge to say something at work, he wrote it in a notebook instead.
戴夫开始纠结这件事。他甚至不确定问题出在哪儿，所以他开始做记录。有一周，每次他在工作中冲动想说点什么时，他就把它写在笔记本里。
By the end of that week, my notebook was full of the most random crap. None of it was a literary allusion.
到那周末，我的笔记本里记满了最随机的垃圾。没一个是文学典故。
Maybe, Dave thought, the problem wasn't him. He'd recently been transferred from the humor department to the serious writing staff. And he was surrounded by all these new people who probably just didn't understand him.
也许，戴夫想，问题不在他身上。他最近从幽默部门转到了严肃写作组。他身边全是这些可能根本不理解他的新人。
I was still doing lunch with the guys from humor. That was what I felt was my real home, and I could be myself there. And so I was at lunch with them maybe two or three weeks later, and one of the guys, as we were going to lunch, said, you know-- and it was a cluster of us, five or six of us, all heading toward the lunch room. And one of the guys said, you know, we do a lot of monkey cards. And yet--
我还是和幽默组的伙计们一起吃午饭。我觉得那是我的真家，我能在那里做回自己。所以两三周后我和他们一起吃午饭，其中一个伙计，当我们去吃午饭时，说，你知道——那是我们一群人，五六个，都往食堂走。其中一个伙计说，你知道，我们做了很多猴子贺卡。然而——
You mean cards with pictures of monkeys?
你是说印有猴子图片的贺卡？
Yes, yes, more or less, because what he actually said was, and yet, they're all illustrated with chimpanzees. And chimpanzees aren't monkeys, are they? And I said-- because I had done a report on this in fourth grade, and because it was something of an obsession of mine, monkeys, apes, and so on-- was I said, actually, chimpanzees are apes, along with orangutans, gorillas, and gibbons. And in fact, one of the weird things about Planet of the Apes is they don't have any gibbons in them. The orangutans that they claim are orangutans look like gibbons. And the way you distinguish apes from monkeys is apes have no tails and they're not exclusively arboreal.
是的，是的，差不多，因为他实际说的是，然而它们都是用黑猩猩来做插图。黑猩猩不是猴子，对吧？我说——因为我在四年级时做过关于这个的报告，而且因为这是我的一种痴迷，猴子、类人猿等等——我说，其实黑猩猩是类人猿，还有红毛猩猩、大猩猩和长臂猿。事实上，关于《人猿星球》的一个怪事是他们里面没有长臂猿。他们声称是红毛猩猩的看起来像长臂猿。区分猿和猴子的方法是猿没有尾巴，而且不是完全树栖的。
And there was this pause. And I said, actually, there's a whole subset of other animals that are like monkeys called prosimians. And they include the lemur, and the tarsier, and the kinkajou, and the galago-- also called the bush baby-- and they're really goofy looking. And boy, if they had a Planet of the Prosimians, I would totally watch that movie.
停顿了一下。我说，其实还有一整类其他动物像猴子，叫原猴亚目。它们包括狐猴、眼镜猴、蜜熊和婴猴——也叫丛林婴儿——它们看起来真的很滑稽。天哪，如果他们有一部《原猴星球》，我绝对会看那部电影。
And there was a further pause. And one of my friends said, oh, Dave, hey, speaking of animals, would you like to see the rat's ass that I give? And I thought, oh, that's my problem. I inform people against their will.
又停顿了一下。我的一个朋友说，噢，戴夫，嘿，说到动物，你想看我哪怕一点点在乎吗？我想，噢，那是我的问题。我强行告知人们他们不想知道的信息。
So what you're saying is that the thing that can be very annoying in the real world is the same thing that makes you really good at solving puzzles?
所以你的意思是，在现实世界中非常恼人的东西，同时也是让你在解谜方面非常出色的东西？
Yes, yes. Although I also feel obliged to point out that perhaps the more important point-- as far as I'm concerned-- is the thing that makes me annoying in the regular world is not annoying here. This environment is one of the only places where I can say something like that and not worry that I might be irritating someone by saying it, that even if it's not relevant, people at least understand the impulse.
是的，是的。尽管我也觉得有必要指出，也许更重要的一点——就我而言——是那个在现实世界中让我恼人的东西在这里并不恼人。这个环境是唯一能让我说出那种话，而不担心可能会惹恼别人的地方，即使它不相关，人们至少能理解那种冲动。
On a puzzle team, Dave can be himself only better. And I think this is true for a lot of people whose talents require the right context in which to shine. Think about it. A boxer without a boxing ring is just a guy punching people. In a puzzle competition, a guy with a mind for obscure facts can be a star.
在谜题团队里，戴夫可以做回他自己，而且更好。我认为这对于许多才华需要合适的背景才能闪耀的人来说也是如此。想想看。没有拳击台的拳击手只是个打人的人。在谜题竞赛中，一个拥有大量生僻知识储备的家伙就能成为明星。
Yes.
是的。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Good job, guys.
干得好，伙计们。
Good work.
干得漂亮。
Lisa Pollak. The 2007 MIT Mystery Hunt was won in 38 hours and 14 minutes by none other than the Dr. Awkward team, whose members immediately began planning for this year's hunt, which was won two weeks ago by the team, Evil Midnight Bombers What Bomb at Midnight. If you'd like to try some of these mystery hunt puzzles yourself, you can find them all by Googling MIT Mystery Hunt. And God have mercy on your soul.
丽莎·波拉克。2007年麻省理工神秘大搜捕由“奥克沃德博士”团队以38小时14分钟夺冠，其成员立即开始规划今年的搜捕活动，该活动两周前被“午夜爆炸的邪恶午夜轰炸机”团队赢走。如果你想亲自尝试一些这些神秘搜捕谜题，可以通过谷歌搜索“MIT Mystery Hunt”找到它们。愿上帝怜悯你的灵魂。
[MUSIC - "SMARTER THAN YOU" BY THE UNDERTONES]
[音乐 - 送葬者乐队的《Smarter Than You》]
Act Three, Girls in Need of a Safer Time.
第三幕，需要更安全时代的女孩们。
Robin Epstein remembers the ad. There was a hospital nursery full of babies. And one baby girl tosses off her pink knit cap. It lands on the floor. This inspires other little baby girls to do the same. Pink hats come flying off of heads. Finally, the first little baby girl raises her little baby fist into the air, as Helen Reddy sings, "I Am Woman."
罗宾·爱泼斯坦记得那个广告。医院的婴儿室里满是婴儿。一个小女婴甩掉了她的粉色针织帽。它掉在地上。这激励了其他小女婴也这样做。粉色的帽子从头上飞落。最后，第一个小女婴把她的小拳头举向空中，海伦·瑞迪唱着《我是女人》。
[MUSIC - "I AM WOMAN" BY HELEN REDDY]
[音乐 - 海伦·瑞迪的《I Am Woman》]
Please, don't stand up in your cars. This was an ad for the Oxygen Network, all-women's network, just about to go on the air, February 2, 2000, which Robin found completely thrilling.
求求你们，别在车里站起来。这是氧气电视网的广告，一个专门针对女性的网络，即将于2000年2月2日开播，罗宾觉得这极其激动人心。
It was this really wonderful moment of, here we go. It sort of heralded our arrival, and the birth of the network, and the excitement behind it. And it felt like it was something really to cheer for.
那是极其美妙的一刻，我们开始了。它某种程度上预示了我们的到来，以及网络的诞生，以及背后的兴奋感。感觉它确实是值得欢呼的事情。
Robin had just gotten a job on a brand-new show on this brand-new network. It was a quiz show for teenage girls called Clued In. Robin was going to write all the questions in the quiz. And she did this with a real sense of mission.
罗宾刚在这个全新网络的全新节目中找到了一份工作。这是一个针对少女的智力竞赛节目，叫《Clued In》。罗宾要为节目编写所有问题。她带着真正的使命感完成了这项工作。
It just seemed like a fantastic idea for a show to me, which was to get teenage girls on a quiz show and to show the world, really, how smart they were.
对我来说，这似乎是一个精彩的节目构想，那就是让少女参加智力竞赛节目，真正向世界展示她们有多聪明。
Show the world and show other teenage girls?
展示给世界和向其他少女展示？
Absolutely. And I wanted to show that these were the girls that you should be looking up to, that there were, in fact, role models that you weren't seeing.
绝对。而且我想展示她们应该是你仰慕的女孩，事实上确实有你没见过的榜样。
Right, and they walk among us. They're everyday girls.
对，她们就在我们中间。她们是普通女孩。
That's right.
没错。
Yeah. Did you know about these studies at the time that-- I think the researcher was named Gilligan.
对。你当时知道那些研究吗——我想研究者叫吉利根。
Yeah, Carol Gilligan. Absolutely. Yes. I think it was basically until the age of 11 or so, girls in class, they are constantly raising their hands. It's important that they look smart. They want to impress their teachers. And so they're constantly all about giving the right answer, and reading, and researching, and whatnot. And then there's something that happens to these girls at age 12 or 13 where it inverts. And suddenly, appearing smart is not important at all for the majority of them.
对，卡罗尔·吉利根。绝对是的。我想研究基本上说，直到11岁左右，课堂上的女孩总是举手。她们看起来很聪明很重要。她们想给老师留下印象。所以她们总是关于给出正确答案、阅读、研究之类。然后在12或13岁时，这些女孩身上发生了一些变化，它倒置了。突然间，看起来聪明对于她们中的大多数人来说一点也不重要了。
And when you began this show, did you know about that research? And did you believe it?
当你开始这个节目时，你知道那个研究吗？你相信它吗？
I absolutely knew about the research. I didn't buy it. I thought, no way. I mean, sort of based on my own experiences in school, I was in a public school, but a lot of my friends were really smart girls. And we were all sort of very pleased with being high achievers and doing all this stuff. And I just thought, that research is a crock. You know, where is this woman going? What schools? How many girls did she actually interview?
我绝对知道那个研究。我不买账。我想，没门。我的意思是，基于我自己上学的经历，我是在公立学校，但我有很多朋友都是非常聪明的女孩。我们都因为成为高成就者并做所有这些事而感到非常高兴。我只是想，那个研究是胡扯。你知道，这个女人要去哪儿？什么学校？她到底采访了多少女孩？
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Welcome back. Welcome back. I'm Ian Kesler, and it's time to get Clued In.
欢迎回来。欢迎回来。我是伊恩·凯斯勒，是时候开始《Clued In》了。
And just describe what the early shows were like, what kinds of questions there were, how people would respond.
描述一下早期的节目是什么样的，有什么样的问题，人们会如何反应。
Right. So in the early shows, we would ask a range of questions. And I thought that there was a baseline of things that clued-in people should be aware of and should know.
对。所以早期节目中，我们会问一系列问题。我以为有些东西是聪明人应该了解和知道的基准。
All right, here's the question. When stocks rise, it's a bull market. What animal symbolizes a market decline?
好，这是问题。当股票上涨时，它是牛市。什么动物象征市场下跌？
[BUZZER]
[蜂鸣器]
Allison.
艾莉森。
Chicken?
鸡？
No. Good guess, but that wasn't it. Janine.
不。猜得不错，但不是那个。珍妮。
A bird?
鸟？
No, that's incorrect. Do you want to give it a shot, Jacqueline?
不，那个不对。想试试吗，杰奎琳？
No.
不。
No, you don't? You don't want to embarrass yourself? All right, so actually it's a bear. It's a bear market. OK, don't worry about it.
不，你不？你不想让自己尴尬？好吧，其实是熊。熊市。好的，别担心。
So is that pretty typical?
这是典型情况吗？
Yes. There started to be a creeping sensation that the questions were way, way too hard when she came out with chicken. That's where I thought, oh, OK, we have a problem.
是的。当她说出鸡的时候，开始有一种令人不安的感觉，问题太难了。那就是我认为，噢，好的，我们有问题。
Here we go. 500-point follow-up, same category. What losing presidential candidate lost the use of his hand in World War II? Three seconds. Emily.
开始。500分跟进题，同一类别。哪位竞选总统失败的候选人在二战中失去了手的使用权？三秒。艾米丽。
Teddy Roosevelt?
泰迪·罗斯福？
No. Anybody else want to give it a shot? Come on. Bob Dole. Bob Dole. Yeah, World War II.
不。还有人想试试吗？来吧。鲍勃·多尔。鲍勃·多尔。是的，二战。
With the girls out there not able to get answers, not able to get these answers, did you ever feel a little guilty? You know what I mean? Like you're doing them a disservice, you're making them look bad.
看着女孩们答不出问题，答不出这些问题，你有没有感到一点内疚？你知道我的意思吗？就像你帮了倒忙，你让她们看起来很糟糕。
Oh, absolutely, every day. It was one of these things where, when they had the blank stares and they were not ringing in on their buzzers, I would sort of sit there and I just had my hand on my forehead, sort of looking down, and just feeling like, what have I done? Like I have put them in this position. It is my fault that they can not answer, that in fact, not only am I not showing that girls are smart, I have put on the air that girls are stupid.
噢，绝对，每天。这是那种情况之一，当她们一脸空白，没有按下蜂鸣器时，我会坐在那儿，把手放在额头上，向下看着，感觉自己做了什么？就像我把她们置于这种位置。她们回答不上来是我的错，事实上，我不但没展示女孩们聪明，反而播出了女孩们很笨的节目。
That's really good. And actually, Lauren, that's wrong, too. So you don't get any points. I'm sorry. All right. Jasmine, are you ready? Here's your first question.
这非常好。而且事实上，劳伦，那个也错了。所以你没分。很抱歉。好的。茉莉，准备好了吗？这是你的第一个问题。
Now, this is a show on a network for women--
现在，这是一个女性网络上的节目——
Yes.
是的。
--and it's aimed at girls.
——而且是针对女孩的。
Yes.
是的。
Why is the host a guy?
为什么主持人是个男的？
Yeah, that is a great question. We actually auditioned scores of women to be hosts of the show. There was one girl who was possibly a good fit for the show.
是啊，这是个好问题。我们确实试镜了许多女性来做主持人。有一个女孩可能是节目的好人选。
And?
然后呢？
And she was not really pretty enough to be on TV.
她长得不够漂亮，不能上电视。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
Mmm-hmm.
嗯哼。
She was good, but she wasn't just pretty enough?
她很好，但就是不够漂亮？
Yes.
是的。
Even on this sort of pro-woman network?
即便是在这种所谓的支持女性的网络上？
Even on the we-love-you-for-what's-on-the-inside network. Yes.
即便是在那种“我们因为你的内在而爱你”的网络上。是的。
And what did you think when you saw that go down? Did you just feel like, OK, well, whatever, it's television?
当你看到这种情况发生时，你是怎么想的？你只是觉得，噢，好吧，随便啦，反正那是电视？
Yeah. I mean, we were TV people, and so there-- and the assumption also was that if we wanted teen girls to be interested, maybe we give them a little eye candy. And the host that we chose sort of had a passing resemblance to Matt Damon. He was like a Matt Damon type.
是的。我的意思是，我们是电视人，所以那里——而且假设也是，如果我们想让少女感兴趣，也许我们需要提供一点眼球福利。我们选择的主持人长得有点像马特·达蒙。他属于马特·达蒙类型。
And here's the question. What amendment gave women the right to vote?
这是问题。哪项修正案赋予女性投票权？
[BUZZER]
[蜂鸣器]
[? Kocey. ?]
[听不清]科西。
There you go, [? Kocey. ?] It's all you.
给你，科西。全看你了。
Eighth? Ninth? 14th? 15th? Eighth?
第八？第九？第14？第15？第八？
Three seconds.
三秒。
Ninth? Eighth? Ninth? Say Ninth.
第九？第八？第九？说第九。
The Ninth. No, wait.
第九。不，等等。
No, no, she didn't say it.
不，不，她没说。
She said Ninth.
她说了第九。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
I'm going to guess 14th.
我打算猜第14。
That's incorrect. Actually, it's the 19th Amendment. 19th Amendment.
那个不对。事实上是第19修正案。第19修正案。
None of us deserve the right to vote, because we don't know that.
我们中没人应得投票权，因为我们不知道那个。
That's true, exactly. So nobody gets the final question.
那是真的，没错。所以没人答对最后一题。
None of us deserves the right to vote. Yes, exactly.
我们中没人应得投票权。是的，没错。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So the girls can't answer most of the questions that you designed for the show. What do you do?
所以女孩们回答不上你为节目设计的大多数问题。你怎么办？
You dumb down questions. You give them things that anyone of any age, of any mental capacity could possibly answer.
你把问题变简单。你给她们任何年龄、任何智力水平的人都能回答的东西。
Jesus is known as the son of whom?
耶稣被称为谁的儿子？
[BUZZER]
[蜂鸣器]
[? Fane. ?]
[听不清]费恩。
God.
上帝。
God, that's right. So you're up to 4,000 points. Abby, you've got 3,250. Which one do you want to go with?
上帝，没错。所以你有4000分了。艾比，你有3250分。你想选哪一个？
All right, I'll take This Spells Disaster.
好的，我选“拼写灾难”。
This Spells Disaster. Here's the question. Without fumbling, who can spell her first name backwards?
拼写灾难。这是问题。不许结巴，谁能把她的名字倒着拼出来？
[BUZZER]
[蜂鸣器]
Katie.
凯蒂。
E-I-T-A-K.
E-I-T-A-K。
There you go. She's on the board.
给你。她上板了。
Yeah, that wasn't one of my prouder moments as a question writer.
是啊，那不是我作为出题人最值得骄傲的时刻。
Which one would you like to go with?
你想选哪一个？
I'll take Sign Me Up, please.
我选“让我加入”，请。
Sign Me Up, all right. This is actually a physical challenge. We want to see who can get an autograph on their arm from the cutest boy in the audience.
让我加入，好的。这是一个身体挑战。我们想看看谁能让现场最可爱的男孩在她们胳膊上签名。
[BUZZER]
[蜂鸣器]
All right, Rachel, here you go. Here's a pen. You've got 15 seconds. Go right now. 15 seconds. Come on, cheer for her. 15 seconds.
好的，瑞秋，给你。这是笔。你有15秒。现在开始。15秒。来吧，为她欢呼。15秒。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
So in this one, they're running through the audience with pens. And isn't this pretty much exactly the kind of boy crazy culture that you were trying to not encourage?
所以在这个环节里，她们拿着笔在观众席中奔跑，这不正是你试图不鼓励的那种疯狂追星文化吗？
Yes. This was pretty much exactly the opposite of what we were trying to show with the show. And that did kind of made me sad that here are these-- they're the ones who are on air and who should be the role models. And it was pretty disappointing to realize that, even though we were trying to find them and to show this, we were failing at it.
是的。这几乎与我们试图在节目中展示的完全相反。这确实让我有点难过，因为她们是上了电视的人，应该成为榜样。意识到即使我们在努力寻找她们并展示这一点，我们却在失败，这真令人失望。
What would be your dream car?
你的梦幻车型是什么？
Um, I guess my dream car would be a Mustang.
嗯，我想我的梦幻车型是一辆野马。
A Mustang. Like a new one or an old one?
一辆野马。新款还是旧款？
Whatever. Like, I probably--
随便啦。像，我可能——
And so, when you got into this, your whole idea was, like, OK, let's show how smart girls are. And at the end of this experience, how did you feel?
所以，当你进入这个行业时，你的整个想法是，好，让我们展示一下女孩们有多聪明。经历过这一切后，你感觉如何？
I felt girls are dumb.
我觉得女孩很笨。
Girls are dumb.
女孩很笨。
Just listen to yourself.
听听你自己说的话。
I know. This experience remains one of these things that I'm not entirely sure how to explain. I do think women are smart. But the lesson of what I saw versus what I want to believe is very different.
我知道。这次经历仍然是我完全不知道该怎么解释的事情之一。我确实认为女性是聪明的。但我所看到的与我想相信的东西之间的教训是非常不同的。
But is it possible the girls were smart but just not smart in a way that could be made apparent in a trivia quiz?
但有没有可能女孩们很聪明，只是不是那种能通过智力竞赛展现出来的聪明？
Yes. I just think that, for a lot of it, the girls seemed much more interested in just sort of showing this really superficial side to themselves, that it was all about sort of what they looked like, and it was all about how they were presenting themselves, as opposed to what was more on the inside, or what seemed like good things to achieve.
是的。我只是认为，在很大程度上，女孩们似乎对展示自己非常肤浅的一面更感兴趣，即一切都是关于外表，一切都是关于她们如何包装自己，而不是内在有什么，或者什么看起来是值得实现的。
I wonder if just in the end your mistake was you just thought more people were like you than really are. And that's the mistake that runs the world, basically.
我怀疑最后你的错误只是你认为有更多人像你一样，而不是真的那样。那基本上就是运行世界的错误。
Yeah. I mean, I think that's probably the case. Probably not many other girls were spending their weekends playing Trivial Pursuit with their friends. But I no longer feel like it is mine to try and improve the quality of girls. That was maybe an idealistic something that I had in my 20s.
是啊。我的意思是，我认为情况可能就是那样。可能没多少其他女孩像你一样花周末时间和朋友玩“Trivial Pursuit”智力游戏。但我不再觉得提高女孩素质是我的任务。那可能是我20多岁时的一种理想主义的东西。
Because you don't think they need it or because you think it's hopeless?
因为你不认为她们需要它，还是因为你认为那没救了？
Because I don't-- I'm not sure it's possible.
因为我不——我不确定那是可能的。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah. I'd like not use the word, "hopeless," but hard, certainly. And I don't know what can. I think there's just-- I mean, I think that there can be a role model, per se, that maybe could have this influence. But it's not a game show. Certainly coming up with a quick fix, or a quick answer, or ringing in for something at the buzzer doesn't seem like the long-term solution.
是的。我不想用“没救了”这个词，但肯定很难。我不知道什么能行。我想那里只是——我的意思是，我认为可以有一个榜样，也许能产生这种影响。但它不是游戏节目。当然，提供快速修复、快速答案或按蜂鸣器回答问题，看起来不像是长期解决方案。
Robin Epstein in New York.
纽约的罗宾·爱泼斯坦。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself. Bob Harris, the Jeopardy champ that we heard from at the beginning of our program, has written a memoir about how he won and then lost on Jeopardy called Prisoner of Trebekistan.
我们的节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己制作。我们在节目开头听到的《危险边缘》冠军鲍勃·哈里斯写了一本关于他在《危险边缘》获胜又失败的回忆录，书名叫《特雷贝克斯坦的囚徒》。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, where you can find our free weekly podcast, absolutely free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以找到我们的免费每周播客，绝对免费，www.thisamericanlife.org。本节目由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
And the show that we originally had been planning for this week, with the theme, Tough Room, which includes a visit to the very tough room that is the editorial offices of The Onion , will be here next week. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who has this announcement, that I believe will come as a great relief to mothers everywhere.
我们原定本周播出的主题是“艰难的房间”，其中包括对《洋葱报》编辑室这个非常艰难的房间的访问，下周将播出。本节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他有一个公告，我相信这会让全世界的母亲们感到极大的宽慰。
I no longer feel like it is mine to try and improve the quality of girls.
我不再觉得提高女孩素质是我的任务。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。